we've already thought a lot about two by
two transformation matrices as being
able to map any point in the coordinate
plane to any other point or any
two-dimensional vector to any other
two-dimensional vector what we're going
to do in this video is generalize a bit
and realize that the same principles can
be used for n dimensional spaces now i
know that sounds a little bit fancy and
it really is on some level but it's
really the same ideas so for example
let's extend what we know about two
dimensions let's extend it to say four
dimensions
so let's write a four dimensional vector
here and it is hard to visualize in four
dimensions so don't be hard on yourself
if you have trouble two dimensions not
too hard three dimensions not too hard
four dimensions a little bit hard for us
maybe we have to think about time as the
fourth dimension but in matrix world or
in vector world it's pretty easy to
represent them as hard as it is to
visualize so a four-dimensional vector
will just have four numbers negative one
let's see negative three i'm just making
these up randomly negative five and one
this is a four-dimensional vector and we
could view it as being a weighted sum of
the unit vectors in the different
dimensions of four-dimensional space i
guess you could say it you could say
that this is the same thing as actually
let me color code a little bit this
would be equal to negative 1
times the 1 0 0 0 vector
plus
negative 3
plus negative 3
times the 0 1 0 0 vector
plus
negative 5
plus negative 5
times the 0 0 1 0 vector i think you see
where this is going and then last but
not least plus 1
times the
0 0 0 1
vector
now when i write it this way you might
immediately start realizing oh i think i
know how to do transformations here for
example
if i were to give you the transformation
matrix and this would be a
transformation matrix for four
dimensions
so it's going to be a four by four
matrix so i'm going to write some random
numbers here 1 0 negative 3 negative 1
two zero negative three one
three
two
zero two
three
negative one zero and three so my
question to you is
what would be the mapping of this
four-dimensional vector if we were to
apply this transformation to
four-dimensional space what would be the
result pause this video and think about
it
well it's completely analogous to what
we did in the two by two world in
two-dimensional space
we thought about all right instead of
the one zero zero zero vector we're now
going to use this vector
instead of the zero one zero 0 vector
we're now going to use this vector
instead of this one in that blue green
color we're now going to use this one
and last but not least instead of that i
guess we could say salmon colored vector
we're now going to be using this one
so another way to think about it is this
the mapping of this vector let me write
it this way let me make a little line
here so we can separate things a little
bit
but we could write i'll write it a
little bit smaller hopefully you can see
this so this is our original vector
negative 5 1.
but we want to do the prime what does it
get mapped to under this transformation
well this is going to be negative 1
instead of this unit vector right over
here it's going to be negative 1 of this
one right over here so it's negative 1
times
all of this business 1 2
3 and 3
and then we could have just instead of
plus negative 3 i could just write minus
3
times
all of this business
0
0
to negative 1
and then we have
minus 5
times
all of this business
negative three negative three
and then we get zero zero
and then and that definitely gets a
little bit more a little bit more work
involved the more dimensions we have
plus
one times this business so plus 1 times
negative 1
1
2
3.
and so what's this going to be equal to
so and actually this could be a good
time to pause the video too and have a
go at it
all right so this is going to be this
first one i just make all of these
negatives so negative 1 negative 2
negative 3 negative 3.
and to that i'm going to add let's see
if i multiply all of those times
negative 3 i'm going to get 0 0
negative 6
and positive 3.
and then if i multiply all of these
times negative 5
i am going to get
15
15
0 and 0
and then if i multiply all of these
times 1 well i just get those things
again
so that's going to be negative 1
1
2 and 3 and we are in the home stretch
so now we can just add everything
together the corresponding terms and so
this is going to be
negative 1 plus 0 plus 15 plus negative
1. so that's going to be the same thing
as 15 minus 2 which is going to be 13.
the negative 2 plus 0 plus 15 plus 1. so
that's going to be 16 minus 2 which is
then we have negative three plus
negative six which is negative nine
and then we add two to that so that is
negative seven
and then negative three plus three is
zero plus zero is zero plus three is
three and we are done we have found the
mapping of this four dimensional vector
based on a four by four transformation
matrix very cool